معنى
الان السيده
الحاجه محمد البشير هي صاحبه هذا المنزل
حرج اول الحمد لله على سلامتكم بتقولي لي
ايش صار معكم والله اللي صار معنا كلنا
قاعدين في البيت ما بنعرف ايش في برا
كاينين مبلغين جيرالنا يعني انتم ما
اتصلوش فيكم وببلغكم
بعد ما طلعنا وشردنا من البيت ايش اللي
خلاكم تطلعوا طيب اللي خلاني اطلع جيراننا
طلعوا اللي هم دار سيلفي يعني لموا حالهم
وطلعوا لما شفناهم طلعوا بصرخوا بصوتوا
وبقولوا رنوا علينا رنوا علينا طلعت انا
انا لحالي يعني في البيت وابني كان في
الدكان تبعته وهذا في المحطه التاني الولد
الكبير
وبنتشر قلت له وين بدنا نروح قعدت في
المحطه بعد شويه مبلغين طلال
جارنا جابوه اجى محمد بقول يا جماعه
اليهود رنوا علينا مخابرات اسرائيليه على
اساس بدكم بدو ينقصف
قلنا طيب ان الله احسن من كل الناس قعدنا
شويه
ضربوا ثلاث صواريخ الاف 16 واحنا قاعدين
يعني في المحطه بعد شوي اجى صحفي بقول لك
شو قاعد بتسوي انا اطلع بره الحين طلعنا
وشردنا بعد ما طلعنا من المحطه خبطوا
الدار اربع صواريخ 16 يعني بالاول ثلاث
صواريخ
الاربعه في الاخر تدمير يعني
واهل الدار اللي بتقولي لي انت واولادك
ساكنين واولادي واحفادي كنا طلعنا شردنا
قبل ما كانوش لا ما قالوش انه والله ما
حكوا لنا غير طلال عواد بعد ما رنوا على
ابن سيلفي ما بلغنيش ابن سيلفي ولا حكينا
اما جارنا بلغ اجا للاولاد وقال لهم على
اساس ضربه مقصف وايش اخذتي لما غير تبع
صلاه طلعت فيه والله ما اخذت معي واولادك
والله نسوان واولادها هي بيحطوا لهم
كل واحده معها بيبي على ايدها بالكفوله
طلع والله بالكفوله طلع النسوان وقعدنا في
المحطه ونستنى رحمه رب العالمين اللهم
قصفوا الدار قبل ما شردنا قبلنا خوفنا
الشضايا تيجي علينا وفعلا جيراننا هذولا
ظرفاير حاره عندهم شبابيك وين عندي ساكن
برضو واحد يعني كمان الجيران بيوتهم
ايش اسمك
مريم ايش اخذتي من الدار طلعتوا
وين العابك في شنطتك اخدتيهم لا
قطب اللي في الشنطه العبك معك اخدتيهم
طب وين انت قاعده هلقيت من الليله لهلا
جيرانكم يعني قاعده عندهم
طب وانت ومين طلعتي من الدار انا وماما
وستو شفتيهم وهم بيقصفوا الدار اه شو صار
طيب ان شاء الله بتكون عندك دار احلى
حبيبتي
اذا هكذا يكون وضع
المواطنين في هذه المناطق هو انذار مفاجئ
فقط من قبل طائرات
المسيره يطلق صاروخ او صاروخين وبعد فتره
قصيره جدا لا يسمح لاهالي المنزل او حتى
اهالي الحي باخلاء المنازل او باخذ اي من
ممتلكاتهم ويتم قصف هذه المنازل